[music]
It was a year of difficult necessary decisions
[music] of
the most important steps towards gaining full
sovereignty of Russia
and powerful consolidation of our society.
It was a year that put a lot of things in
place, and
they cynically use Ukraine and its people
to weaken and split
Russia
[music] in the
coming New  year
[music]
rallied to destroy us our us and
our children
[music]
apparently to my husband Just something, some kind of
greeting from home in the form of a piece of Sal I don’t
know any of his favorite cigarettes
icons and there
was no opportunity to personally hand over
the parcel to him and We also decided with the girls, the wives
of servicemen,
that there are no friends and foes.
Let’s collect Hello everyone from home
here we have our volunteer
they are called Victory Volunteers
Hello If only
there was an opportunity
[music]
America happened and  people understand this all
perfectly well
and people have been united by this grief has
united us, in fact, now it’s
clear who the real enemy is
[music] it’s
unpleasant to listen to this all the people
[music]
yesterday an appeal from women who
send us their own
January 1 called  I was given
data on them, that they are alive, that they are
just at hot spots, that they
cannot contact you, I agree with
everything, please help me, I beg you
to find these guys, soldiers,
now the situation in Russia is extremely
alarming,
people were not afraid to speak
[music]
open sources reported that during the
withdrawal of Russian troops,
a huge amount of
Russian equipment, weapons, ammunition was left to the enemy, all
of this is now being used against Russia
[music] [
music]
the important thing is that we are all mortals, we are all under the
Lord
and we will all be out of this world someday
let's leave
and your son
understand and
asked
[music]
plans
Yes, and mom,
but I just understood that there was no
other way, that is, in fact,
I tried all the documents at that time,
look at the legal procedures, they
practically don’t work now
their effectiveness is very
Ksenia got it low because she
screamed a lot, didn’t listen to anyone,
didn’t believe anyone and fought until then, actionism
progressing,
I remember this now, even
then I’m sitting and there’s a borderline state
between the desire to laugh and just roar out
loud because, well, you  It’s like
you’re achieving something and there’s this one step
forward and three steps back, and every time it
seems that the situation is about to be resolved
somehow, but nothing happens. Very very
rare Victories inspire,
they inspire, they give hope But there are
very few of them,
just some...  then a shaky hope that things
will change
[music]
[applause]
[music] [
music] [
music]
right
Why why not Why not
join Russia,
we are not imposing ours on anyone right
[music  ]
in the end
[music]
I went to Donbass let's call it not
Ukraine let's call this Donbass I go to
Donbass only on a humanitarian mission I
work on helping children these are
children's libraries these are orphanages these are the
children of
large families where the soldiers died I
bring
medicines I bring textbooks toys
educational games books
[music]
[music] [
music] [
music]
Well, I don’t know because the Nazis
[music]
My Motherland is not only Russia, my Motherland is the
USSR Soviet Union I was born, I received an
excellent education  in the Soviet Union there is a
decent upbringing and I cannot be
against my Motherland Even when I
do not always approve of some of the steps of
our government But now I believe
that it is necessary to end this war, which
began long before February, it
needs to be finished long ago to
unite All peoples because the people of
Ukraine are  the Russian people are one people and
we should not be divided like the
Belarusian
[music]
from the Moon is
not that they are against war Well, it just so
happens that from almost all families
someone there doesn’t say much
what the guys  young people die a lot, they don’t
write a lot, they just don’t want to be there and mothers are
fathers; it’s a
totalization region in which people
live on loans and need to somehow
survive.
Propaganda tells people in every possible way
that they need to pay
for the money they offer to go there
[music] [
music]
[music]
[  music]
here in Russia It seems to me People don’t believe
in themselves We all have some kind of
We are used to putting
the state above ourselves for some reason We have a lot of people who
support Putin, they think that without him the
country will fall apart, as if we have
more here besides him  there are no worthy
candidates and everyone just lets
go,
everyone has died,
someone is lying without legs, someone is lying without
half a head, I have a relative who
came, he went as a volunteer, it
turns out, and he went for company with
friends, he was never interested in
politics, he lives in  in the village it turns out they
offered him a good salary
when he arrived, we expected him to drink We
expected him to drink,
but he arrived and he didn’t drink for a week. He
cried for a week
because there were
very few of them with whom he went; they survived; he arrived with a wound in the
thigh and  he said that there was
nothing left of his friends, just
dust
[music]
[music] [
music]
look, the Russian Mishka was sleeping, he was
sucking his paw, he didn’t touch anyone, they came up, they beat him, they
spat on him, he was sleeping He was sleeping,
but they woke him up, they woke him up
[music]
now pray  and Russia never
started a warrior, Russia is finishing them
[music]
I would like everything to become
as quickly as possible
But today we cannot do this
because we see how the West, as I already
said, is putting out this fire with gasoline
[music]
but the mobilization is not over,
this is a fact of trouble
and the Ukrainian people stand
behind the
Ukrainian army,
no one stands between a colossal disaster and the Russian people
[music]
now people are still in the 21st century killing
each other also according to some rules
for me This is savagery I can’t accept this
one question
in general how is this  it might end well
[music]